[Musique]
juste après les fêtes les vaches de
Pierre Lapointe sont finalement rentrés
au bercail à la suite d'une longue
écouteuse opération menée par le MAPAQ
qui n'a d'ailleurs pas encore été
chiffré les vaches vivaient en liberté
dans la forêt depuis des mois sans que
leur propriétaire ne parviennent d'aller
ramener dans leur enclos
Radio-Canada a appris grâce à la loi
d'accès à l'information que la ferme de
Pierre Lapointe a un volumineux dossier
ou ma pack en plus d'avoir reçu plus
d'une dizaine d'avis de non conformités
entre 2010 et 2018 alors qu'il
l'exploitait avec son père il a écopé de
cinq constats d'infractions
en 2016 la loi sur le bien-être animal
n'a toujours pas été payé l'inspecteur
qui s'était alors rendu sur les lieux
des pleurs que plusieurs vaches et vous
sont gardées dans des conditions insalub
il indique que plusieurs vaches ont les
ongles ont long et que des bas vins
présentent des signes de maigreurs ils
notent la présence de moisissures dans
les mangeoires des veaux et d'oiseaux
mortes dans l'abreuvoir extérieur les
veaux ont les pattes les flans et le
ventre croutés de fumier le plancher et
les murs sont recouverts d'excréments
solides de couleur bruneâtre peut-on
lire le rapport d'infraction va être
donné justement là quand les correctifs
ont pas été apportées ou que la
situation a été jugée suffisamment grave
la vétérinaire Émilie Pelletier indique
que la loi sur le bien-être animal qui
date de 2015 prévoit que le lieu doit
être salubre propre et convenable c'est
sûr que le bien-être animal c'est une
préoccupation qui sociétale d'ailleurs
justement la notion de bien-être animal
évolue dans le temps ça change vite ça
change très vite oui oui ça coûte
beaucoup
d'argent ah oui surtout avec la cavale
ça serait le pays là après avoir
minimisé la situation Pierre Lapointe
admet avoir été dépassé par la
réglementation en constante évolution
lors de notre passage à sa ferme il
attendait l'aide d'un consultant pour
moderniser c'est façon de faire ils
viennent nous aider à nous mettre sur le
plancher en réalité que ce soit alors là
au lieu de parler des vaches à cavale si
on prépare un peu de détresse
psychologique chez nos producteurs le
président de l'UPA Mauricie qui s'est
impliqué activement comme d'autres
producteurs locaux dans la capture des
vaches refuse de lui jeter la pierre il
ajoute que les normes québécoises sont
parmi les plus strictes au pays oui
c'est bon pour les animaux bien-être
animal l'environnement mais il y a aussi
l'autre côté c'est que ça l'amène une
surcharge au niveau des producteurs et
c'est ça qui commence à être un peu
lourd à supporter le Mac a refusé de
nous transmettre les dossiers les plus
récents dont ceux concernant la cavale
parce qu'il est possible que des
démarches en justice soient entreprises
ils ont changé de place
malgré tout Pierre Lapointe retient du
positif de toute cette histoire
toute la gagne et du vous êtes belle
quand vous dormez vous êtes belle
ici
Radio-Canada Saint-Barnabé